i like to watch comedians the way other
people listen to music i like the the
ebb and the flow and the way it and i
like you know the way they talk
so one day rodney's on the tonight show
and he's sweating a little bit like he
always does
and i'm watching him he's a little like
this you know and he's getting the
laughs and i said to debbie our producer
i said call the paramedics i think
rodney's having a stroke she don't want
me to talk about i said i think he's
having a stroke just called paramedics
just just call him okay
well he did have a stroke
and they took him to the hospital okay
so i went to see him in the hospital and
he gets high hospital
and they had another stroke a little
while later and this one laid him out
this is he was in a coma
so joan calls me one day and she says uh
j ronnie's in a coma and he
he can't see any i mean he can't
react to anything but i think
he can hear us
so would you i said yeah i'll car sorry
go on i'm talking to rodney you know and
john says to me
and ronnie's lying there
and john says
rodney
uh
she goes jay put your finger in rodney's
hand
rodney if you know it's j just squeeze
his finger if he can
so i put my finger in his hand i feel a
little squeeze and i go rodney that's
not my finger
so rodney does this
and she goes ah he moved came out and
john goes he moved he moved and and he
moved and i said oh and i felt so good
that i made rodney laugh you know and he
didn't he died soon after that but but i
i just remember that i just remember he
went he liked this because he did hear
the joke and i thought
yeah and yeah it's about to laugh and it
was yeah it was really a tender moment
and just one of those moments that
really make you tell that to some people
oh how horrible but a comic's
understanding no
yeah
i remember i remember uh patrice o'neil
oh boy he was a great cop unbelievable
comment we're at patrice's funeral right
and you know every every comic from new
york jay
came to patrice's funeral we're all
there
and
comics start to go up and you know our
speaking
and saying things just about patrice and
the funeral slowly morphed
into one of the best comedy shows
that
that you've ever seen i'm talking
rich voss colin quinn
jim norton bill burr myself
keith robinson i mean you you you name
it you bob robert kelly uh i mean the
list goes on and on but comics were
coming up and giving their best
15-minute sets but involving patrice and
it really made you understand we speak a
language of our own right right and and
that language that we speak always
it always involves the laugh there's
nothing more important than the last and
that's that's what we always want and
you know i think sometimes
it's hard for
people today to understand that a comic
means no real harm he's going after the
laugh and in doing so
you know the [ __ ] can happen in the
comments like oh my god i stepped in it
but he was just trying to go for the
laugh because that's that's the most
important thing give me another comic
right that
that you have had personal experiences
with like that has really impacted your
life oh kevin rooney uh wow uh oh
they're just so many uh well seinfeld so
we all started out you know when we
started all the comics would come to one
another's tonight show you know people
think it's like this horrible cutthroat
business but other comics will always
get you more work
than any agent you know steve martin
brought johnny to see me wow and and
harvey corman brought johnny in to see
me again and uh you know i brought uh
johnny in to see um ellen degeneres and
and and we all helped one so so johnny
at this point you know in in this era of
when you were coming up johnny was the
oh yeah but yeah he was the the mecca
like it was until the end yeah sure wow
oh yeah wow and it was
and and was johnny was johnny um
was he receptive like was he a guy that
that was open about you know expressing
who he felt was funny or who he thought
well you have to understand we were
young we weren't kids we were young
adults in our early 20s johnny was a man
and you know i grew up in a house where
he he said mr carson i wouldn't i
wouldn't call him johnny uh mr carson
call me johnny would you so that was
always awkward when i do the tonight
show with him because it was a car it i
just felt weird so when letterman got
his show and i go hey let him a nice tie
you know and i could trash him like i
would in a club or something and it just
became much looser so there was always a
reverence and respect for johnny that
it wasn't like he was another comic he
was the comic you know it's it's like
eddie murphy
to my generation oh sure right so eddie
would occasionally pop into
comedy clubs right he would occasionally
pop in and sit in the back and when
eddie came in
you always knew because comics just kept
looking up right every comment just kept
looking up and the reference was eddie's
up there and for some reason there was a
thing
that you felt you felt like if you
looked up
and you saw eddie laugh
well that equaled success right to some
degree it equaled oh my god oh it did it
it's a different stamp of approval yeah
because if he liked it it's i mean it's
gold i mean there were so many shows you
did merv griffin and mike douglas but
johnny carson was the one that put you
on the number if johnny laughed well
then that was
you